ja der satz flimm hat genauso wie das
bild bei uns in den wahlkampf reihen
denn bisher waren der viele in der union
überrascht manche von ihnen auch
tatsächlich wütend dass angela merkel
sich bisher gar nicht eingemischt hat in
diesem wahlkampf armin laschet
gewissermaßen in dieser verheerenden
werte hat rein laufen lassen und vor
allem nicht deutlich gemacht hat es gibt
nur eine angela merkel und der aussieht
wie olaf scholz ist auch olaf scholz und
nicht die neue angela merkel das hat sie
jetzt ganz ganz deutlich gemacht viel
deutlicher hätte man das eigentlich gar
nicht sagen können sie hat gesagt
gewaltiger unterschied uns herz gemacht
bei einem thema was für olaf scholz
tatsächlich eines der schwierigsten ist
nämlich bei der frage würde er sich von
der linkspartei den nachfolgern der
menschen die wenige meter von diesem
studio und menschen an der berliner
mauer erschossen haben er würde er sich
von denen zum kanzler wählen lassen
darauf hat olaf scholz bisher bei dirk
einem interview druckst er herum
gedruckt über herumgedruckst und wir
haben zehn minuten lang versuchen ja das
war ein schritt aber wir zehn minuten
lang versucht und nicht diese drei
klaren worte ich mache es nicht gefunden
und jetzt hat angela merkel deutlich
gemacht zwischen dem der so tut als wäre
ich olaf scholz und mir besteht ein
gewaltiger unterschied er wurde sie
wurde übrigens gefragt nach dem wort
erbschleicher ein wort was claus strunz
hierbei bild live geprägt hat was in den
tagen darauf übernommen wurde in der
union das ist jetzt der vorwurf
erbschleicherei und sie hat ganz klar
gesagt olaf scholz keine angela merkel
denn mit mir würde es ganz sicher
niemals die linkspartei in einer
bundesregierung geben das kann ich
ausschließen oder schließt es nicht aus
und sie nennt es gewaltigen unterschied
vor allem ist das ein gewaltiger schlag
für olaf scholz es ist ein schlag für
olaf scholz kann das jetzt auch armin
laschet helfen jan jetzt in diesem
debakel in dem er sich befindet mit so
schlechten werten wenn er jetzt mal ein
bisschen rückendeckung von der kanzlerin
bekommt also das ist glaube ich dass wir
gerade sagte vollkommen richtig dieses
stoppschild für den erbschleicher
erbschleicher und indirekt damit auch
unterstützung für armin laschet der ja
im trie l eigentlich eine ganz gute
figur gemacht hat und auch versucht hat
olaf scholz und annalena baerbock zu
attackieren was bisher ein bisschen
fehlte und deshalb werden gerade auch
gesagt war natürlich die unterstützung
der chefin der bundeskanzlerin den in
das büro von ihr möchte er einziehen so
und die hat es mit dem heutigen tag
gegeben was eigentlich brisant ist auch
an der aussage von angela merkel ist
dokumentiert noch immer ganz klar das
was olaf scholz macht hat vor allem
taktische motive er will möglicherweise
den preis für eine koalition
beispielsweise mit der fdp hochtreiben
und das ausgerechnet mit der partei die
oder als nachfolgeorganisation
verantwortlich ist für die mauertoten
hier in berlin und überhaupt in
deutschland also von daher dieses
taktische spielchen dem hat angela
merkel heute den stecker gezogen also
noch mal ganz kurz warum ist dieser
moment da im kanzleramt vor wenigen
minuten so wichtig gewesen die deutschen
vertrauen angela merkel wie keinem
anderen politiker wenig etwas vielleicht
noch markus söder aber sie führt nach
wie vor die popularitätsskala deutlich
an und diese frau warnt jetzt quasi
wahlkampf deutschland vor olaf scholz
und einer koalition mit den linken wenn
angela merkel sagt olaf scholz ist nicht
angela merkel dann ist olaf scholz für
die deutschen nicht angela merkel und er
war auf einem sehr guten weg sich so zu
positionieren dass es eben angesprochen
als sich fotografieren lassen mit der
raute er hat im trial gesagt angela
merkel und ich wünschen uns sogar angela
merkel und ich sind der meinung er
bezieht sich ständig auf sie und jetzt
diese kanzler klatsche kann man fast
sagen für olaf scholz
verbunden mit etwas was man ja fast als
warnung bezeichnen muss ja man kann fast
sagen angela merkel hat hier vor olaf
scholz gewarnt hat vor dem szenario
gewarnt dass man olaf scholz den moderat
wirkenden hamburger sozialdemokraten
wählt aber dann mit den sozialisten von
der linkspartei eine regierung aufwacht
für davor hat sie die deutschen hand
klar gewarnt und ich glaube viele in der
union denn das ist das woran man sich in
der union noch festhält vor genau an
dieser an dieser warnung vieler in der
union sind sehr dankbar dafür dass die
bundeskanzlerin jetzt nicht nur
wahlkampf zb bei greenpeace macht wie
gestern abend glaube ich weiß natürlich
er auf die grünen ein zeit sondern jetzt
endlich mal sich zu einer der ganz
zentralen wahlkampf position ihrer
partei oder wie sie sagen wurde der
partei der sie nahe steht der union
bekennt es ist natürlich auch ihr r
merck eine war
1 zu fahren dann also wenn der kandidat
ist nicht ins kanzleramt schaffen sollte
dann wäre das natürlich auch eine
niederlage für angela merkel und dessen
ist sie sich offenbar jetzt langsam auch
bewusst also bei umfragewerten von 20 21
prozent für die union hätte sie dann ihr
eigenes erbe mit verspielt und ich
glaube sie ist jetzt auch sich dessen
bewusst zu sagen das sollte besser nicht
passieren das wäre würde am ende negativ
in den geschichtsbüchern auch über ihre
kanzlei weil man sich in den letzten
tagen tatsächlich gefragt hat möchte sie
tatsächlich ein cdu nachfolger im
kanzler ich habe es eben erwähnt sie
nennt die partei noch die partei die mir
nahe steht das ist die partei der sie
ihre ganze politische karriere ihren
sagenhaften aufstieg was tut man gutes
auto zwei der männer steht man hatte ich
hatte zeitweise das gefühl so eine grüne
kanzlerin dass angela merkel quasi als
diese letzte große cdu ära in den
geschichtsbüchern ganz alleine steht
würde auch gar nicht so schlecht passen
wissen wir nicht aber was wir jetzt
wissen olaf scholz hat sich heute
richtig eine eingefangen für saas was
claus strunz erbschleicherei nennt
[Musik]